how you doing people i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report direct message it's
october 28th 2021 we are streaming live
on rumble.com
youtube and blazetv wherever you're
watching don't forget to subscribe if
there is a notification bell tap it you
could share our videos tell
friends and family alike about them and
uh maybe post them on other social media
sites and see how long it takes you to
get banned although that won't happen on
rumble or on locals obviously a lot to
talk about today it is thursday so we
are doing a q a we got dozens and dozens
of questions from my locals community
you still have a chance if you want to
try to get into question because i've
been doing this for about a half hour
reubenreport.locals.com the pin post
right now is uh me asking for your
questions so you can try to get one in
and i did want to cover one thing before
i get to some of the questions because
you know my feelings about this ron
desantis guy i had dinner with him on
friday night at a fundraiser and he is
he is the real
deal this is a guy who
speaks from the hip this is a guy who
knows what he's talking about
this is a guy who's defending freedom he
is standing up against the machine and
all of that stuff and i saw a tweet by
one of his pr people this morning i
believe she is his press secretary
christina pusha that's a great last name
and here's the tweet in florida there
will be no covid19 vaccine mandate on
children that is the law and that is
from
governor ron desantis so this is the
only story that i want to cover before
we jump into the
q a because i was making me think the
way this is going to be framed and i saw
already some of this responses online
and the way mainstream media is covering
it is that ron desantis wants to kill
children
that's what he really wants to do he
wants to murder as many children as
possible or as i talked about yesterday
on msnbc where they said that ron
desantis wants to kill old people
because he's bringing in law enforcement
that want to move to florida because
they're not happy with vaccine mandates
wherever they live he's bringing him
into florida and as that lunatic i mean
a true lunatic the woman is joy reid on
msnbc said that basically he's bringing
them in so they can cough on old people
in florida and kill them so the
narrative around desantis is he wants to
kill old people and he wants to kill
young people of course neither
of those things is true as a matter of
fact uh the numbers have just come out
over the last couple days and if i'm not
mistaken can we completely double check
this but i'm 99.9 sure i'm telling the
truth here uh florida has the lowest
numbers of covid right now okay so uh
and whether it's the lowest or the third
lowest i'm pretty sure it's the lowest
the point is he kept the state open he
keep he's keeping people working he's
inviting law officers yes according to
yahoo news dave rubin knows what he's
doing florida now has america's lowest
kovid rate so he's not trying to kill
children he is not trying to kill old
people he is not trying to kill
middle-aged people he's actually
looking at data
he is looking at the numbers and he is
listening to the professionals who are
not trying to manipulate us and keep us
masked and locked down and with 87
booster shots forever so that is pretty
great here a little bit more from yahoo
florida's daily average has plummeted by
more than 90 percent to about seven uh 1
700 cases or 8 out of every 100 000
residents that's roughly half of
california's current coveted rate and
less than a quarter of vermont and as
we've talked about many time related to
florida they have the second oldest
population in the united states and he
still managed to make sure people could
go to work he still kept the schools
open and everything else i have a
feeling there's a couple questions about
florida in the q a i've been tipped off
on one or two so let's get right to it
amy says what are you most looking
forward to with the rumble acquisition
of locals so of course this is what most
of the questions were about this week
and as i said to you over the last
couple days i am going to try to be as
transparent and honest and real with you
as possible about why we did the deal
the reasons that i think this was the
right deal to take and and just all of
our policies going forward i mean what
was exciting me because i told you i
could have just walked the way the deal
was structured i could have just taken
the stock and walk i didn't have to
continue as being part of rumble or
locals but not only do i love the rumble
team they've just got great people i
talked about chris the ceo the other day
and obviously dan bongino and a whole
bunch of other people that are involved
that are fighting for the things that
that i talk about on the show all the
time it wasn't just that it was that i
want to be
one of the people that helps craft
policy for a tech company you know jack
at twitter and cylon mark zuckerberg at
facebook and the rest of them it's like
they're so distant from all of us
there's no way you can trust them
there's no forward-facing person at
these companies that you feel like is
actually kind of looking out for you and
it's like if i can do a little bit of
that if i can communicate if i can help
craft and then communicate some of the
policies
to you guys like that's awesome that
that to me is something not only
something that i would want to do but
something that you know is using my
skill set well and i think that is
something that is needed as we build
this parallel ecosystem so i would say
i'm looking forward to that i'm also
looking forward to the fact that we are
building great tech not only did we
build everything at locals ground up and
with our code and built all of the stuff
that's what they were acquiring in
essence
rumble has incredible infrastructure as
i talked about so you know when amazon
aws just knocked out and blew up parlor
it's like that can't happen to us now so
even though there was a huge part of me
and trust me uh myself and my partner
assaf and a few other people involved
some of our advisors and investors like
there was a huge
um
feeling like oh maybe we should just
continue maybe don't sell now because
our growth is so great and like let's
figure it all out and then there was
this other piece of you know we're at
this very weird cultural moment it feels
like we're in the midst of an of a
political revolution cancel culture like
big tech blowing up servers the whole
thing we were like well maybe this is
the moment to team up with people who
have some of the pieces that we don't
have and we have some of the pieces that
that they don't have so when i talk
about the puzzle pieces coming together
i don't know exactly what the puzzle
looks like when it's complete but i know
we're starting to piece it together and
it's starting to look pretty good so i'm
excited to to communicate the ideas and
policies to you guys i'm excited that
we've got the right tech and i'm excited
that we will find all sorts of other
companies to work with and we will build
an ecosystem outside of this crazy
leftist big tech lunacy that that is my
commitment to you and it's a commitment
to myself actually perry says we keep
saying things will get worse culturally
and politically before they get better
what does the bottom look like
after michael can you scroll a little
bit more for me please what does the
bottom look like after which things
start improving
um look that's the million dollar
question right so i think everyone that
sort of got their head on straight right
now is looking at what's going on in the
world and going man
it's it's pretty bad right like supply
chain stuff we know about gas prices
going up we're seeing food not on
certain shelves uh michael said to me or
showed me a picture a couple days ago he
went to get a prescription filled showed
me the pharmacy here in la and it was
like pretty barren back there like
you're all seeing verges in the versions
of this and on top of critical race
theory in the schools and just just like
everything the media melting down like
all of the stuff you guys all know the
stuff um so the question is how bad does
that all get like what does that rock
bottom look like i don't know the answer
and i've asked this to a million people
actually i interviewed dr drew in here
yesterday it'll be up next week and uh
and we sort of got into that as well
like nobody really
knows what rock bottom looks like i
would prefer that we don't hit rock
bottom you know when someone's an
alcoholic or a drug addict everyone says
well they gotta hit rock bottom like
whatever that means meaning they've
completely ruined their life or lost
their job or lost all their
relationships or end up in jail or
whatever horrible situation you can
think of that's what's happened to them
it's like that's what i don't want to
happen to america i think that's what
i've been trying uh and not just me you
guys by watching this and talking about
these things in your own life and a
whole bunch of other people like that's
what we're all trying to fight like
let's not hit rock bottom rock bottom
would be pretty horrible like it would
be i would say it would be unimaginably
horrible because there would be there
would be more violence on the streets we
would have an economic collapse
all sorts of terrible things so the best
we can do is build new things like that
stuff is going to keep going down all of
these big companies that have brought in
diversity and inclusion hr departments
they will destroy their own products you
really have to understand that like that
is the key to this whole thing
uh and i will talk to i haven't disc
brought it up yet i brought it up in
like some very informal phone
conversations but i'm going to talk to
the rumble guys like i want to make sure
we never have a diversity and inclusion
uh organization or advisors at rumble
and at locals okay and by the way on
just quickly on that front we're also
going to keep those the companies are
going to keep operating separately we're
going to share resources but we're still
running
uh locals as is just important to note
but they will destroy themselves in the
name of diversity inclusion they won't
hire the best engineers they won't hire
the best doctors they won't hire their
best pilots all of that could lead to a
pretty bad rock bottom right you want to
be on a plane with the best pilot you
want to be
getting heart surgery from the best
doctor not a doctor because he's a black
one-eyed lesbian like that's not he's a
black one-eyed lesbian i probably got
booted misgendered the black one-eyed
lesbian
anyway you get the point um
so whatever rock bottom is
i don't know but i know that the best
way to avoid it is to start doing
protections in your own life to avoid
that rock bottom make sure you're not so
reliant on the system that is going to
hit rock bottom actually this is very
much what my next book is about don't
burn this country which comes out in
april like getting off the system stop
being so reliant on a system that really
just wants to take your money and abuse
you
we're now in an abusive relationship
with the federal government and and many
of us are in an abusive relation with
our state governments here in california
for example
i would uh juxtapose that with what's
going on in florida where it's it's a
real it's a real symbiotic relationship
it's like oh i'm going to free you
people as much as possible to live your
lives and the people go oh i'm going to
live my life as much as possible and
good things are going to happen and
their economy is blowing up and real
estate's blowing up because everyone's
moving there and all sorts of stuff so
what does rock bottom look like i don't
know but trust me i don't think we want
to find out and that's what we have to
avoid
uh duane says as a business owner in the
gig economy i want to accept crypto and
money in a place where they can't shut
me down at the root source for any
reason for example i want to trust my
pos in the locals rumble universe where
can i bank and uh wallet my money this
is a great question so this is one of
the things where i want to communicate
the ideas we're working on i can't share
everything but we are working on payment
processor stuff this is one of the big
things right because it's not just they
can cancel you off twitter
or off facebook or you might lose your
job if you say something or everything
else it's like what happens when banks
start calling half the country diseased
racist and then chase says oh
you you voted for for orange man or you
had this opinion about gender pronouns
we're not going to open up an account
with you now we have another problem but
this is what i mean about a parallel
economy we are going to build and we are
building the new
structure so there's a limit on how much
i can say about that specifically but
we're working on payment processor stuff
this is a huge key to all this by the
way this is also why crypto and bitcoin
is so important decentralized payments
where you can't just be cut off because
one guy says okay cut them off or
because a board
you know 20 people in a room say oh we
don't like these people they're not
going to be able to bank with us etc etc
so this is where decentralization will
kick in this is where alternative
payment processors will kick in and
everything else so stay tuned on all
that and and my hope is that it's in the
not too distant future that i'll have a
little bit more for you uh margot says
with all of this fantastic news i must i
must ask are you getting any quality
rest keep it up you know what i went to
sleep believe it or not
i went to sleep at 9 30 last night
i don't remember the last time i went to
sleep that early i just we were laying
on the couch
we were watching seinfeld that's usually
what i do to shut down at the end of the
day well actually we watched one episode
of downton abbey we're now in the final
season we're re-watching it we're in so
i think it's season six i think we're
about episode four almost at the end of
the series then we put on one episode of
seinfeld and my eyes were getting heavy
heavy and i usually kind of fight it for
a while and sometimes i actually like
first passing out on the couch
and we don't have a tv in our room i do
not believe in tv in in the bedroom um
but i sometimes like passing on my couch
but my eyes were going down i was like
you know what i have been doing so much
stuff the last couple days and all of
this craziness and making the steel go
through and everything else i was like
i'm gonna go to bed
at 9 30. and then of course my reward
for that was my body didn't fully adjust
i was up at 6 00 a.m this morning so
there you go but i'm feeling energized
i'm feeling good and and i i'm not
i'm not
being facetious or over the top when i
tell you i can see the good stuff in the
distance now which is what i've been
looking for for weeks especially since
the disastrous recall here in cali like
the alternative stuff it's it's being
built and even in the last couple days
seeing more and more people out on the
streets in new york city firefighters
and policemen and regular folks out
there
screaming against mask mandates and
people showing up to the brooklyn nets
game to protest in favor of kyrie irving
make a medical decision for himself all
of these things the parents that are
showing up to these boards all over
these school boards all over the country
to say hey we don't want our children
taught racist nonsense in the name of
diversity it's like people are waking up
so let's just keep going let's let's get
a little juice in the system and let's
keep running with it
sarah says what are your thoughts on
facebook's tv ad that is apparently
inviting regulation on big tech curious
timing airing just as the locals rumble
deal is announced seems like the zuck is
gaming congress to secure his platform
and torpedo everyone else so this is a
great point and and this is something
that people really need to understand at
some level
if you are the big boys right now if
your facebook your twitter your
instagram
youtube the whole shebang right
you want regulation now why would you
want regulation you want regulation
because a that means you don't really
have to fully do your job the government
can kind of tell you what to do so now
you've sort of outsourced a little bit
of your decision-making power which
makes it kind of easy for everybody but
it also sort of cements that you will be
the big boys forever once the government
comes in and says you companies have to
do things a certain way that stifles
innovation so now the new companies that
are coming up on the way that are trying
to do all sorts of funky things and
might have different people with
different voices and diverse viewpoints
on board well now they have to play
within those strict confines of whatever
the government regulation is right and
this isn't just related to speech it's
related to building codes and whatever
else there might be whatever the
government might want to regulate
usually pretty much always stifles
innovation it might have good intentions
right it really might and i'm not
sitting here saying that we should have
no regulation whatsoever i think there's
an interesting libertarian argument for
that i've talked about it for a long
time or that you could privatize
all sorts of uh regulations building
codes and things there's some argument
around that that's not exactly the
argument i'm making we can have some
possible sensible
regulation
but yeah i do think it's possible that
at some level zuckerberg's like man i
built this company i'm worth gazillion
dollars but boy do i have an endless
headache when it comes to speech and the
culture wars and politics and everything
else if only the government could just
basically say to us hey you can't do
this you can't do that boy that would
save me a lot of time and a lot of
headache
and
to your other point i do think that they
are quaking in their boots a little bit
like people are not
like loving facebook anymore are you
even on facebook are you on facebook
like personally not really are you on
facebook like no like i'm not on
facebook we have a we have a page for
the show
but you know no young person's like mom
i'm getting on facebook today like
facebook is sort of ending which is why
they're really pushing this multiverse
right is that what it's called this new
multiverse that facebook is pushing
right now because they basically want to
turn us all into ready player one the
movie they want us to be online even
more and just that will live in a
digital world much like the matrix
that's the new thing that they're
pushing is it called the multi the
multiverse or the
what's it called the multiverse or no
it's called the
uh
what is it called facebook creates a uh
did you yeah it's a zuckerberg's vision
for a digital universe but it's not
called the multiverse what's it called
multiverse is from spider-man maybe it
is the multiverse anyway we'll get to it
we'll get to more of that in a sec the
metaverse thank you the metaverse okay i
knew i was getting close uh and what is
the metaverse it's a concept related to
vr and ar involving creating digital
worlds that multiple people can inhabit
at the same time so basically the
direction that facebook wants to go
right now is that if any of you have an
oculus or if you have uh playstation vr
that you will enter these digital worlds
and this is pretty much what ready
player one was about they want us to
live in these worlds forever and you'll
just get you know you'll sit at home all
day and you'll eat out of a bucket
you'll eat bugs out of a bucket and
you'll pretend that you're a music
superstar in this digital world that's
what maybe that's why they're trying to
destroy the real world because they want
this to be as bad as possible so that
we'll all be begging to be in
zuckerberg's multiverse or whatever the
hell it is anya says will you be hiring
now with the uh rumble merge yes we will
absolutely so right now uh whatever you
do if it's in the tech space if you're a
programmer
if you're a coder whatever you do i mean
we need people in hr we need people and
everything so on the locals front you
can just email
your resume to jobs
locals.com i don't know specifically
what rumble's hiring for but i do know
that they just uh got some new offices
and it might be in a certain sunshine
state was i allowed to say that i'm not
totally sure uh so there's good things
happening there and i know a few of you
were worried that
rumble was a canadian company because
that's where it was founded in canada
obviously has horrible laws related to
free speech that are only getting worse
uh so again maybe they have a
building somewhere in florida that
they're going to move into soon and i
don't want to wouldn't we're not
streaming this aren't we and nobody can
hear me if i don't really move my lips i
think we're okay uh patrick says what
hairstyle adjustments are you planning
to deal with for the florida humidity
patrick but what does patrick know um
well first off i feel like i'm having
quite a good hair day today and it's a
perfectly beautiful day here in los
angeles with no humidity which is always
good for the height
i am actually going to florida on
saturday
on the 30th
there is the national conservatism
conference i'll be there along with
peter thiel and ayan herciale and josh
hawley and marco rubio and chris ruffo
and give me a couple other names liz
wheeler will be there
uh ted cruz will be there it's just it's
just michael knowles it's like an
all-star reuben report reunion basically
uh i'm doing a couple speaking gigs
there oh douglas murray will be there uh
yoram hazoni i mean lots and lots of
reuben report people you can still get
tickets can we make sure to link to to
the event in the description we'll link
to the event so that you guys can still
get tickets so i will be there and
locals is one of the sponsors of the
event so i'll be doing interviews
throughout whoever we can just grab as
they're given their speeches and
everything else i'll be there from the
30th to the second and then i am
sticking around in florida from the
third to the seventh or so
i have my reasons
okay
mike
what are your thoughts on the republican
senators grilling attorney general
merrick garland during his testimony
yesterday do you think he should resign
because of his memo directed at parents
yes if you didn't see this so this was
happening just as we started the show
yesterday which is why we didn't fully
cover it on the show but i i briefly
mentioned it
there is some
absolutely incredible exchanges so
merrick garland is testifying about this
memo that went around that basically was
calling parents who were showing up to
school board meetings to tell the
administrators that we don't like you
teaching children critical race theory
we don't like all of this gender lunacy
we don't like your that you're telling
them that two plus two equals five
instead of four just all the stuff then
this memo sort of came out which
basically was like these people are
terrorists and we're to have domestic
terrorists and we're going to have to
look into them and probably follow them
and god knows what else we're going to
do
and basically
tom cotton specifically but everybody
cruz went after him josh hawley like all
the few good guys that we've gotten
we've got a couple of them just
absolutely demolish them the one clip uh
we should have had it ready for today
we'll we'll get it to you guys uh tom
cotton just completely demolished him
and said you have got to step down like
this you are an embarrassment he was
going to send basically the fbi and the
cia to look at parents who who just want
to make sure that their kids aren't in
effect being intellectually abused
at schools so merrick and merrick
garland by the way could not come off as
less impressive he's just so
unimpressive and and befuddled and just
like mealy mouth nothing um so it's a
good thing that he's not on the supreme
court but he should not be attorney
general but this is one of those things
where what the progressives do is the
worse you are at your job the either
longer you will stay there or the more
quickly you will get promoted they love
incompetency because they're all well i
think there's a couple of reasons why
they're all sort of incompetent to one
degree or another but when you put
ideology before truth it's like no
matter how bad things get you keep
doubling down on it that's why they
double down no matter what goes on it
doesn't matter okay there's bad crime so
what do we do we get rid of police now
it gets worse what do we do we blame the
police like you saw the ilhan omar video
we did yesterday they're just terrible
so merrick island should step down i i
suspect he will not uh christine says do
you have a plan in place in the event
that apple and or google decide to
remove the locals or rumble apps from
their play stores they did that to
parlor and it just about destroyed them
so very quickly uh you all know that
really what happened to parlor was the
the
servers being blown up amazon aws
servers amazon web services aws they
blew them up and destroyed parlor and
parlor basically had 23 million users
and they went from having 23 million
users and like a business that was
probably going to get tons of money and
be able to scale and do all sorts of
great stuff they just absolutely
destroyed the competition i've called it
a mafia move many times it's like a new
guy comes into town right there's a new
guy and it's like oh if you have bigger
guns and more men on the street you just
take them out you don't mess around you
just take them out so that's what they
did
on that but that being said
apple did take parlor out of the store
ios store and then i believe the android
store was taken out a little bit later
over the course of months as parlor
changed a few things in their terms of
service they are back in those stores
but your broader point is well okay the
two big stores exist like how are you
guys going to make sure you stay in them
well first off
it's a huge problem like i'm not going
to pretend it's not a problem the fact
that these two stores in essence control
what so much of us put on our phone now
there are ways around it by the way
there are some ways around it but it's
often quite complex it's not you know
unless you're a techie you don't really
get to
get fully how to do it there's been some
talk that elon musk is working on his
own phone and maybe app store as well so
there is hope and by the way that would
be the competition part of this that i
like my goal would be that for now we
stay on those stores as long as possible
and as i've told you guys many times
especially on the local side of things
it's like man we have such great
fun decent conversation going on on
locals because there's a paywall so
there is no bad behavior it's like just
think of all of the horrible i mean
horrible stuff that is said constantly
all day long on twitter but nobody ever
is like i wonder how much longer twitter
will stay in the app store right so that
tells you a little bit about how why the
politics part of this is so confusing so
to be clear i want to stay in those
stores as long as possible i know the
entire rumble team wants to stay on
there as long as possible we also want
competition we want other ways to work
around those stores and maybe build new
stores as i said elon musk might be
doing um but you know we do have terms
of service we do have terms of service
and if you break the law you're going to
be in a lot of trouble and that means
you're going to be in more trouble than
rumble's going to put you in or apple or
anything else so again i don't want to
over promise there's no perfect system
yet we're trying to piece all these
things together and by the way you might
be hearing a helicopter over my house
i'm not sure if they're coming to get me
right now but if so i've enjoyed all of
this and uh you know i'll try to
communicate with you one way or another
there's been helicopters all day long
maybe
maybe o.j got out
oh there was a shooting oh it's la there
was a shooting in the area how about
that i did not know that good to see you
guys uh all right michael says i really
enjoyed movie night with the reuben
report community dave what movie would
you suggest and do you think locals live
chat and rumble could integrate with
netflix or other copyrighted media so i
don't know how quickly say netflix is
going to be integrating with us but
there are third party things like
netflix party which is what we've done
for the reuben report movie nights i
would like to do one you know i haven't
seen dune yet i know most people saw it
already david was traveling for a couple
days so we didn't get to see it yet i've
heard some pretty good things about it
so far not all perfect things but i'm
trying not to pay too much attention um
but yes i would love to do more of that
i mean i think the next step is how do
we link
sort of social media and our ability to
communicate with each other with media
companies so that we can have more
interactive experiences because when
we've done movie night when and we did
interstellar we did v for vendetta we've
done contact uh we did idiocracy a
couple others
we do have a live chat going and it's
fun watching things with you and seeing
how we all are reacting at the same
times what we agree on what we disagree
on and then we have a live video chat
after so we will do a movie night soon
if you want to be part you can always
join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and by the way
our growth the last couple days was
absolutely spectacular so good things
are happening um was it a mass shooting
by the house or just it was just a
regular it was just a
uh
oh okay it was something it was
something somewhat legit all right i'm
not gonna mention that because it
probably gives away a little too much um
okay uh payton says favorite ice cream
ice cream flavor there's a segue for you
i love the cookies and cream i love the
cookies and cream and by the way i will
give a shout out not a sponsor but i'm
gonna give a shout out to tillamook who
is a dairy company they've been making
ice cream now their cookies and cream is
just so damn good trust me ben and
jerry's those two old ridiculous
socialist buffoons move that stuff over
you don't need that stuff they sold the
company for 350 million dollars to
unilever a giant capitalist evil
corporation anyway so they're frauds at
every level and their ice cream is
overpriced and ain't that great
tillamook cookies and cream and they've
also got one called monster cookie not
cookie monster okay because there's
obviously copyright issues monster
cookie pretty damn good jill says is
there a way for supporters to invest in
your new venture even on a small scale
is that even needed so i'm glad you
asked this because i had been telling
people in the local community i've been
trying to figure out a way to get small
people just not small people just
regular people to be able to throw in a
couple bucks so that we could figure out
a way to get people to invest
and we
it's extremely complex like this is not
totally my department you know figuring
out how you like create a fund with a
bunch of random people that don't know
each other that aren't accredited
investors and all the things so we tried
a bunch of ways to figure it out to get
people to uh invest in locals you know
then what also happened is
because our growth was so good and our
burn rate was very low we had money and
it was unnecessary to sell more of the
company and it would have actually been
a bad idea because when you get acquired
they look at the cap table why do you
have all these people if you have all
this money
anyways a lot of complex stuff
but my hope really is that as we grow
this new venture as rumble continues to
contin and continues to grow and as
locals continues to add fuel
to that machine
that there will be investment
opportunities
down the road like that really is my
hope and i want everyone to get in on
this and i would not have done this deal
if i didn't believe in it and i
certainly wouldn't have done this deal
for stock if i didn't believe in it you
know we had all cash offers like i could
have taken an offer that would have
completely changed my life i probably
could have retired all together and just
disappeared but i wanted to stick around
for you guys it was it was for michael
and conroy i said no dave say no to the
money keep working you know what i mean
keep being productive
but we could have done that and i i took
an all stock deal because
or we took an all stock deal because we
believe in this we believe in the
mission statement and the company and
want to continue it to grow
linda says do you think that the let's
go brandon chance in sports and music
arenas are affecting the younger
population's view on the biden
administration i do
this is why memes are so important you
know like
you can spread memes faster than you can
spread ideas if you can get a good
picture with a couple words on it that
that says something true that lights
something up in somebody and usually
it's because it's funny right it's like
man you can make them think in a
different way and then suddenly we get
these chants out there let's go brandon
chance and they start spontaneously
happen happening at sporting events all
over the place and now they're starting
to happen just at events on the street
at bars and all sorts of stuff it's like
that's what authoritarian governments
hate more than anything else when the
people
start doing something when the bottom up
starts doing something and it's funny
and it's real and it's relevant they
hate that they absolutely hate that so
this guy who's the guy that wrote this
let's go brandon song that was number
one
on uh
apple music it was number one and then
they deleted the song or something right
isn't that right give me some give me
some info on that there was a guy
basically who had this let's go brandon
song and then somehow it got deleted but
it was number one if i'm not mistaken on
the apple charts his name is bryson gray
and you can find the song i assume
somewhere let's go brandon but the point
is it's it's cool because it's
spontaneous and it's fun
and by the way you know if you're at a
sporting event game you don't want to be
chanting f joe biden because there's
kids there right like you don't want to
be doing that but you can't let's go
brandon
kids don't know what the hell it means
it doesn't even matter the parent can
make up whatever they have to make up um
and and then it's fun and it's like
people have had it people have had it
with this authoritarian government they
really have so good good for the people
is what i would say uh so bryson gray
that's his name he wrote a song called
let's go brandon it was banned on
youtube although it is still on apple
and it bumped adele off the top slot
poor adele but she has lost some weight
so she's all right uh pool party says uh
no now they're gonna say i'm a fatafold
right i'm just saying she looks she
looks better she lost weight right like
you know
although sometimes as a singer you want
to have a little heft to you because
then you can get you know you can really
exhale because you get all that weight
in then
like that
pool party says if the state department
is issuing passports with the gender x
can i finally go full austin powers and
get mine to say yes please that's funny
uh yes if you didn't see this the state
department is now putting on passports
you're allowed to choose gender x as if
you're an x-men i guess i mean it's all
so stupid by the way the state
department also yesterday was national
intersex day which in essence is if
you've got a penis and a vagina we
didn't need a day for that
we're we're in a clown country at the
moment but but the silver lining and
this is why i'm hopeful it's like
they're giving us they're throwing
everything at us right now like
absolutely everything and if the if the
scariest people we have to fight are a
bunch of genderless unicorns on
tick-tock and aoc
and nancy pelosi and old joe biden it's
like i like our chances it doesn't mean
we're going to win every time it doesn't
mean that bad things won't happen along
the way gavin newsom is still the
governor here but it's like
they're showing us what they got and it
ain't that much it scared a lot of us
but it hasn't scared all of us i know
more people are feeling it right now and
let's keep running with that so uh if
you would like to play along uh go to
rubinport.locals.com as i said we're
doing live chats during all these shows
and you can communicate with me directly
and you can submit a question for next
week's live q a and tomorrow's round
table will be former white house
spokesman sean spicer author eric
mataxis and did we confirm liz she told
me yes so i'm going to go ahead and say
it liz wheeler will be our third guest
tomorrow
on the reuben report and then i'm off to
florida for a bunch of stuff maybe we'll
do a little meet and greet
while we're down in the sunshine state
and i have my reasons to go down there
okay what am i on trial here you know uh
and yeah there'll be a locals booth
there so if you do join uh come on by
say hi hope to see you guys there have a
great day adios amigos